you're watching the game spot co-op
stage sponsored by lego star wars the
force awakens I'm so excited this end we
are back live on the game spots co-op
stage here at e3 sponsored by lego star
wars the force awakens I'm your host
Chris waters and I am joined by andrea
renee i just seen n jeff cannata and
we're about to talk about some call of
duty infinite warfare yeah we all saw at
the press conference and one of us saw
it behind closed doors oh hello's what
you've seen yeah they showed an
additional level behind closed doors
it's zurich and its Space Station zurich
no no real zurich actual on earth zurich
it reminded me I was like this is kind
of terminator the video game cuz it was
a lot of robots there were a lot of like
automatons that are coming out of doors
everywhere and everything was really a
misty and smoky and dark and it was at
night and it was chaos and it was it was
very impressive were they humanoid like
operable to black ops 3 like those guys
yeah it looked like exoskeleton like
thinner than a human could be and I like
an exoskeleton that's why I reminded me
of terminator you know I was like oh my
gosh this is like what an awesome
Terminator video game would be sounds
like a little bit more of a traditional
call duty setting on earth and you know
like interior spaces mostly or no it was
back and forth interior spaces out
outside spaces stuff happening all
around you going in going out you know
your teammates are calling out stuff
let's take a shortcut sure lasting a
wall open going into a building okay I
mean very you know that turned to 11
call of duty single style campaign-style
yeah did you have the grappling hook in
that section no okay let's talk about
that because I think the space setting
the zero g and grappling hook are going
to be huge for this game and the
single-player experience you re a year
of grappling hooks guys yeah I do it at
long last yeah I'm really onto no no
there was no Jon Snow on display my
favorite think about like all the call
of duty campaigns is even though I'm so
into multiplayer so usually most of the
time I'm like I'll play halfway through
the campaign and then like right back to
multiplayer but I love
I always get the great cameos like Kevin
Spacey and then they had up oh my god
what's a guy from SVU I don't watch I
didn't know that was gonna be a test
yeah I'm not ready christopher meloni
thank you for the audience oh my god I
love me p in the audience thank you
window so they have Kit Harington in
this one so it's gonna be interesting I
mean I love space who knows about call
of duty in space and I know there was a
huge backlash with the the trailer
launch and it was like one of the most
disliked videos ever which was kind of
just 10 sec coming from what are people
so upset about you're getting like the
video because of the video I think they
were just liking it to show that they
could do something on the internet it
wastes their time I was that is a
sprawling at a trailer was right I mean
over a million just likes clearly people
are doing it just is the thing like I
want to get in on ya people love to hate
call of duty right and it's unfortunate
because Activision has does such an
amazing job with this franchise I mean
it continues to sell year over year over
year and it wouldn't if it was trash
right like if they were mucking it up
putting out broken games with really bad
stories or you know you know broken
multiplayer it wouldn't keep being
successful so I think it's not fair the
rap that call of duty gets because I
enjoy my time with it every every year
what I play it's interesting because
Activision has sort of done the same
thing at e3 every year and I had this
moment when I was sitting there there's
always like a behind-closed-doors
theater experience for call of duty and
I was sitting there in in that room
going man this brings back memories to
when I saw the because they show the
remaster of warfare that's super
exciting yeah and I think a lot of
people too are really excited about that
because that's what they started with in
college ed so to bring that back and if
you do like pre purchase it then you get
it a month earlier which is kind of
exciting it's awesome but I had this
moment when I was sitting there going I
remember seeing this in a theater in
almost the same space and everybody was
pissed because it was modern war we
don't want modern warfare we want if
that was a hate World War to do yeah
totally everybody hates it until they
love it and then they love it until they
hate it you know look I love multiplayer
so I
I'm super excited for the announce of
anything MP but as far as like the
single-player stuff goes I mean it's fun
you know it's I think sometimes people
take it a little bit too seriously I'm
like it is a video game you know at the
end of the day it's call of duty it's
basically the same thing just a little
bit different we're gonna play it so
that's really a bit so let's talk about
how it's a little bit different because
you know the level Jeff was describing
seen behind closed doors sounded like
all right sticking with your strengths
doing the call duty thing but what we
saw during the press conference
especially on the exterior of the ship
in truce a few interesting things I
think I zero-g combat and also that
grappling hook really introduces a level
of sort of not just verticality but also
like there could be dude shooting me
from anywhere realistically cuz I'm in
frickin space and spaceship Batlin
that's pretty ballsy to be like yo call
of duty is now in space I think that's
really cool and another thing that
occurred to me when I was watching it is
remember when there were load times guys
I mean the demo that they showed was
that Zurich level and at the end of it a
spaceship lands the guy gets into it
launches into space and he goes through
the atmosphere gets into space and now
we're fighting in space then he lands on
a thing and gets out and I mean it's
just all one continuous experience and
I'm like that's ink that's incredible I
remember when it was like next level
let's get now yeah let's do it let's do
a little briefing will show you the
satellite images and where are you going
yeah wasn't I flying a spaceship we do
that in a lot of games we talked about
eve valkyrie in the previous segment you
know x-wing experience coming out lots
of opportunities to fly spaceships are
you excited to do it in call of duty
yeah call of duty excelled at giving you
so much variety in the single-player
campaign you're not just gonna fly one
kind of spaceship i have to imagine
you're gonna fly multiple different
kinds of ships we're going to be in some
kind of crazy tank on the ground I mean
they always easy tanks throw something
new at you with each level and I love
that about the campaign because it keeps
it fresh she keeps it exciting you never
know like what's the next experience i'm
gonna have in the next mission and maybe
that tank will turn it into the
spaceship and it will be like Star Fox
of Duty just be interesting to see what
they're gonna do with that
in multiplayer you know especially with
eSports because a lot of the games they
have to be sort of altered to have like
the specific like play settings because
we don't want to have one team to have
more advantage than the other so it's
gonna be cool to see how they do that
it's gonna be interesting to see how the
eSports community reacts ok that's
sniper keep shooting me I'm doing a
space let's get later on space I mean
yeah Justine you're big into the
multiplayer scene you've been on the
call of duty multiplayer seen for years
and years now I we're looking ahead to
call duty XP where they're going to be
doing the announcer later this year
maybe gamescom what are you hoping for
from multiplayer I mean it's been
interesting to you know we see the up
and up coming of eSports so I think
they're gonna really need to do
something to step it up to take it to
that next level because i think you know
it's been sort of a struggle kind of
getting the community to rally around
all these different renditions of call
of duty so we don't really know what to
expect you know i just want the
community to really have a good solid
game and just to keep following through
because it's also been interesting you
know before it was all xbox xbox xbox so
now its PlayStation so that was a huge
transition this past year for everybody
to sort of just be like all right we got
to go on this new platform now gotta get
a different controller going I think
they'd certainly have a lot to prove
particularly with multiplayer and
esports I spoke to Jay yesterday on the
call of duty eSports team and then I
asked him I said you guys planning to
continue supporting black ops 3
competitively after infinite warfare
slon chand he said no that the
competitive scene for world league is
going to move to infinite warfare so I
mean that puts even more added pressure
not only on the you know people that
like to play for fun at home but also
all of these teams that compete at such
a high level of play I mean you can't
really change the formula too much we
don't bring eSports into consideration
yeah it kind of makes it unique on that
scene because that yearly iteration you
know as applies to eSports you don't
have these teams sort of having years to
sort of like really dig in I mean league
of legends counter-strike go these games
that are cute dominant on the eSports
scene that's a through-line you know
they're not switching it up but I by the
same token maybe is it is it kind of
like a different kind of event a
differen
kind of challenged it like you got to be
called duty team but you also have to be
versatile because you know next year
something else is different is coming
maybe that turnover actually could it be
keeping it fresh I don't know that's
ously and it's interesting because a lot
of these players I mean even sort of
like halo pros like you said like
counter-strike it is the same game and
you know even that slight difference
some people have a very specific play
style and this is how they play this is
what they're good at and they don't like
guess what you know what advanced
warfare I could move I can't move yeah
you know if you're a good solid player
you're gonna be fine but I think a lot
of people used to stick to what you're
used to yeah absolutely well certainly
some eSports challenges for the szafran
choice overcome another one is going to
be EA this year is launching not one but
two shooters in the fall titanfall two
and battlefield one so he kept these
Titans these are Titanic well with a
one-two punch some might say I didn't
can punch to your mate so these you know
these sort of three games have different
focuses obviously they have sort of key
differences but how do you sort of see
that that crowded landscapes stacking up
how we call duties chances against these
two big titles I think it's certainly
going to split the audience with the
vote as it were I think that you know we
saw them take a little bit of a dip last
year and they're like gargantuan sales
numbers I think it's gonna dip probably
even more so this year particularly with
titanfall 2 coming out the original
titanfall was excellent short experience
but an excellent short experience and
now you have you know Vince Zampella
going up against his like you know it's
all running crew and they brought a
single player campaign which fans were
calling for oh my god were they calling
for it geez I mean it was kinda like it
was i I couldn't be more excited about a
single-player titanfall I mean I had so
much fun playing titanfall but even
though I you know I don't really play
the campaign's I much in Call of Duty I
feel like there was just something
missing it's like where is it where is
this extra added thing that we're
looking for but man I'm excited for
titanfall to that I want to make time
tech me right I would protect me and
then in that landscape of this
futuristic shooters you know
battlefields going back to World War one
we think that that's going to your sort
of pull some nostalgic cokes and of
course the battlefield sort of core
battlefield fans different from call
duty fans those games are fundamentally
different in a lot of ways but that
should be an interesting end of the year
you think I've always been sort of hands
off on battlefield because I've been so
invested in sort of like the call of
duty community and you know that's where
I spend most of my time and I was
actually kind of intrigued maybe go back
and get battlefield another chance oh
yeah why didn't I see you over there I
think so I mean bringing down a Zeppelin
in a giant flaming wreck okay I got to
talk to a lot of fans that were playing
at EA play because this showed a 3 which
is really excited EA was like hey we're
gonna take our experience outside so the
public can come and play these games and
it was like universal praise from
everybody that I talked to I also am NOT
a battlefield person I just never
practice enough to get good and and let
me tell you battlefield hardcore players
you'll tell you when you suck um yeah
not like any other gamers yeah they're
different for your community right it
was interesting because I think a lot of
people that i was talking to on twitter
we're concerned like do the guns feel
historically accurate dude does the
setting feel like authentic and it looks
like it really does and the sniper class
is a perfect example how they were
saying like it's so different than
battlefield 4 because you're taking
these World War one error weapons there
are no like high res scopes like so it's
all like mid-range short range stuff for
snipers though seems allegan I'm into i
watch a justice range combat I like to
run and gun so you know this might be
something that I'm into cuz a lot of
times I had a problem with some of the
battlefield maps I think they're so huge
this is taking so long I'm not a good
sniper I got him to be up close and
personal first time somebody Snipes a
horse out from under me I'm gonna be
like I can't well some interesting
competition for call duty infinite
warfare but also some excitement for the
new scene for that game taking it to
space and of course that grappling hook
we'll be right back live on the game
spot co-op stage here at e3 in just a
minute
you